we've got jesse on the line jesse how
are you hey how's it going
oh focus to not finish buddy what's on
your mind for
john and i to talk about with you today
all right all right so we got a bit of a
situation here
um your parents left on a week-long
vacation
basically um so this has been going on
probably for the past
five years but um so i am i met my
my first cousin i lent him uh some money
i liked him five thousand dollars
um a while ago and um
he still have yet to pay me back and he
told me originally that like you know he
just needs it for a job so like
you know i was like okay no problem it's
family like i'll lend him the money and
then
in two weeks he didn't give me the money
and um i guess that job fell through
and i've been asking him especially like
you know right after i've called him all
the time like kind of
um almost calling him too much like you
know where's the money where's the money
what's he saying it never and i would i
just said to him directly like hey you
know i know a lot
is going on but um you know i did lend
you that money and like
if you can please pay it back i was even
willing to do like a payment plan
things like that right and like he gave
me a little bit so i think now the
balance is like around
um still like three thousand dollars but
now there's no relation
with him i don't talk to him whatsoever
i used to have really good relations
with him
you know his mom my aunt his kids
everything but now it's just completely
completely done and um and broken and
now i'm just at a point where i really
i don't know if i should just keep going
with it and just keep asking
because that really didn't seem to work
i even asked his mom
um she even paid me a a payment one time
and
now i just don't kind of know where to
go from here all right jesse
so you lit him five thousand and he's
paid you back around two thousand
yes exactly yeah and now he now he
doesn't
he's acting like he doesn't know you oh
yeah oh yeah you're a stranger he
actually said
that i'm in the wrong for um for being
childish and not knowing
about responsibilities because he you
know he does have a lot going on he has
a family
right and he kind of put it on me where
like i'm in the wrong but like
i was willing um you know to help him
and to do like a payment i understand
i understand and so i can't wait to hear
dr delonie comment on this
but i'm i'm gonna go ahead and go first
here if you lent him 5 000
and he paid you back 2 000 let me do
this i'm from kentucky
so it takes me a minute you got a three
thousand dollar lesson here baby
exactly you've got a three thousand
dollar lesson and you know what
that's why we talk about whenever you
start to get involved with money and
family
without some some and you had
understanding
you said this was alone he called it
alone but now he's acting like
it's not and i think the best thing for
you to do
is to let it go and for you to be able
to move on because i mean obviously are
you working do you have a job
yeah yeah yeah are you what do you know
about the baby steps
um i'm familiar with them yeah i'm
currently paying off all my debt
uh right now don't don't play with me
jesse my girlfriend and i
what do you mean you're familiar with
them what kind of debt do you got
um i have some student loan debt i have
17
grand in student loan okay i have um a
car
payment as well as also 17. okay and how
much are you making right now i'm making
uh
40 grand a year okay so i i if i'm you i
mean it sounds like you've kind of
gotten there you're frustrated and
irritated about it
which you have every right to be but i'm
gonna count this as a three thousand
dollar lesson move on with your life
and let this be one of those learning
lessons unfortunately
uh because it's not worth the
relationship you know uh and it sounds
like it to me
it's more of your cousin's issue than
yours yeah
when you when you loan money to family
don't
don't
give it to him for all of your badgering
um you can put a price tag on the cost
of that of that relationship and it was
two thousand dollars
you you beat him up you got two thousand
bucks back
does he owe it to you yeah are you gonna
get it no and now you're going after his
mom too
what you gotta ask yourself the other
day is what's it worth right what's it
worth
you got it you got a a taste of his
character you got a taste
of ore and that may not be a fair
statement you got a taste of
some messy situations you found himself
in either way it is what it is i'm with
chris man let it ride
let have some peace in your heart dude
and is it it's a three thousand dollar
expense there you
got a two thousand dollar price tag on
that friendship
man don't go after his mom just stop
yeah i really would and it's it's it's
hard man
i mean especially because you know he i
know jesse used the language alone
all alone well in the buddy and the
cousin cousin
cousin called it alone yeah right that's
why he paid back some of it
and this is one of those things where it
can change the family dynamic
right but i'm gonna say both of them are
at fault here
oh yes you know what i'm not even gonna
say the guy asking for money because
i've been in situations myself man i get
pretty desperate
yeah like uh and i i may ask a question
i normally wouldn't ask
right in those moments someone who loves
me is gonna have to put up that boundary
and protect me help me for myself right
yeah and say man i'm not i love you too
much i'm gonna give you some money
or i'm not i'm i'm gonna say no to you
well you said it the right way
it's one of those where if you're in a
position to do it give it give it away
and and and that way you just mentally
you don't have any kind of hurdles or
issues in the relationship
every time you see him it's not that
weird hey bro that's right i'm calling
you i'm getting after you i'm getting
after
stop where's my money you don't want to
do that